marqueur
nous sommes en piqué quand quelque chose ne va
pas dans un avion c'est très dramatique
et ça se prête à du grand cinéma
on va le rouler qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
rouler prêt on y va
ce qui est vraiment intéressant à propos de
Bob c'est qu'il est pilote  donc le fait
qu'il ait eu cette formation en aviation
lui a donné une voie qui était fascinante,
donc c'était en quelque sorte un maître de
la façon dont vous Linda prétend rien
de moins que l'Amérique, il y a toutes sortes de
nouvelles folles ici ici Rock stompin
Bob a beaucoup d'outils dans la boîte à outils
et il sait comment s'en servir donc mon pote sait
comment travailler avec des gens il sait comment
raconter une histoire quelqu'un m'a mis dans un
avion cassé ce rapport de toxicologie indique que
tu étais ivre ce qui pourrait être la vie dans
la prison
c'est vivant il a juste ce don il a
le don de raconter des histoires et à grande
échelle et intimement les caméras vont
être dans votre fauteuil l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai pu faire un film comme celui-ci
qui a tellement de spectacle était parce que
de tout le travail que j'ai fait
au cours des 10 dernières années et de la constitution d'une
équipe d'artistes numériques vraiment créatifs
qui pourraient venir et rendre ce film aussi
spectaculaire, c'était un
gars actif qui, Dieu le ferait, j'ai entendu
lui dit que ce n'est qu'une
extension de ce qu'il a toujours fait, mais
cela semble différent, nos
enquêteurs ont conclu que l'avion a
échoué, ce n'est pas seulement un type de film
que vous pouvez attendre de cet homme, c'est
vraiment une preuve que je vais me battre.
les jours qui ont précédé l'
accident cette chose est si lourde
tue il y a juste un niveau de maîtrise
il n'y a pas d'autre mot pour utiliser la pure
maîtrise cinématographique en regardant Bob travailler
j'étais plutôt bon